une production du studio sf alors salut
tout le monde
bienvenue ou sans filtre podcast le
podcast où on parle de ce qu'on veut
avec nos invités tati tu paies h quentin
avec moi d'une plante épopée h90 qui
emmène chez votre influence au préfet
s'était pas attaqué à watsa bienvenus le
podcast aujourd'hui présentée par écolo
finesse économique n'est c'est mon
deuxième est que notre mère c'est le jam
de domme motion platine antonov ne
serait que j'ai accès à leur 70e au
québec
donc si vous voulez avoir accès à
n'importe quel jim au québec pendant et
failli quand vous allez voir votre
famille et vous voulez continuer à
grandir comme c'est mon cas à lecce que
ceux qui ont des cours de groupe sur
écran géant et ont des circuits de 30
minutes pour les gens qui sont pressés
et ont des programmes d'entraînement
selon vos besoins
ils ont tout le matériel nécessaire pour
faire un travail de qualité
moi je sais que je vais tout le temps
reconnaît je te laisse matin puis je
vais continuer à y aller parce que c'est
extrêmement abordables puis c'est super
pratique de pouvoir aller dans n'importe
quelle jim donc plus d'informations dans
la description du podcast c'est ça merci
économique ne naisse merci que nos
faiblesses deuxième commence tard
aujourd'hui c'est la brasserie
d'hystérie hochelaga font des produits
ma foi délicieux merveilleux ils ont
donné tout à des produits ici pour qu'on
qu'on les hait c'est pour les cons les
bois puis qu'on les apprécie piscine à
non à épier ceux qui aiment la haye pied
mais quelle posture trop se torcher la
gueule sont à pied qui est faible en
alcool donc moi c'est vraiment parfait
pour moi parce que j'adore la lpp
pilager un podcast afin je veux pas trop
me torcher la guerre ou la mienne
c'était une bière blonde
qui vite parce que j'aime la claque est
délicieuse alors hochelaga ils font des
produits sont basées au québec à
montréal font des produits les biens
régulière sont faites avec des
ingrédients 100% québécois ils font
aussi des spiritueux en canette comme ça
mais c'est du gin tonic fac système
britannique de bois ton ironique
en quinze années qui font des bières
expérimental et des bières seigneur à
jour des produits en constante évolution
côte en charge changement on les aime
beaucoup ce nos commanditaires pour se
battre casting est également les
prochains on va boire leurs produits sur
le podcast
on les remercie beaucoup mécontent que
soit le pays pauvres et on adore des
produits on y consomme mais avec
modération a bien meilleur goût tout à
fait merci flag
sinon cette semaine hommes sur le sans
fil cette semaine sur le sans fil
podcast ici même chez nous on a laissé
morel michaud qui est comédienne qui on
ne peut être que tu as peut-être vu dans
des films tels que wii 3d tels que
junior majeur la série l'heure bleue est
également qui quittant qui c'est en ce
moment que ça se passe une jeune femme
tellement intelligente tellement
cultiver tellement intéressé tellement
politisé à chaque fois qu'on reçoit des
comédiens sur le podcast des jeunes
comédiens ont tout à fabregas type à
quel point seules celles aucun sens ils
sont matures ils sont comme des sages
dans des dents des jeunes car ils ne
sont pas à leurs premiers tours de piste
c'est pas le premier tour de piste sur 7
sur cette terre
alors quelle profondeur
non mais pauvre et c'est une super belle
rencontre avec une fille qu'on a adoré
découvrir on au but de la petite hache
la gauche heurtant avec elle on était
relax c'est une bénédiction compte elle
dans la politique
on est allé dans l'hélico quitter nos
querelles et vegan et féministe
j'ai que du positif à dire sur cette
belle personne
j'espère que vous allez apprécier
discussions autant que nous yes et sinon
dans le fond laisser les commentaires
laissés les top up laisser des étoiles
et c'est tout ce que vous pouvez laisser
qui va nous aider ça fait son bout de
chemin et sans plus attendre compliqué
monique
[Musique]
cet art et merci d'être là
cette heure tardive
ah ouais c'est une loi aussi à huy ah
ouais c'est pas de tournage c'est pas
leur temps non non c'est très lève tôt
mais j'ai l'impression que personne ne
lève tôt sur un plateau tournage
ben c'est trop tôt tu peux pas avec les
trois points tout le monde et de contre
nature
tout le monde est un baba mais ces
grands fauves se lève à 4 heures du
matin ça peut pas être ta routine moi
c'est la personne qui sur ce but le
stade rennais 3
[Rires]
je me rappelle j'ai joué dans pascal ben
pascal plancque freedom qui a analysé
les photos j'ai joué dans son dernier
film qui s'appelle nadia butterflies
natation puis qui est pas encore sortie
qui n'est pas encore sorti mais juste
pour moi c'était j'ai fait quatre jours
piste et inhumain puis moi j'étais juste
dans quelques semaines déjà au québec là
vous me dites qui rendu 5 heures du
matin que je suis ici depuis six enfants
tôt que j'ai fait deux tête mais que je
suis encore sur le plateau hambourg et
d'enquêteurs est nulle part bientôt je
vais aller me coucher chez nous puis que
demain mais moi je suis off mais que
l'actrice principale qui elle est sur le
plateau depuis le sporting début de la
journée et dans toutes les salles qui
elle doit se lever le matin pour
recommencer
ces builds ouais mais c'est vraiment
comme un marathon vtt comme sur
l'adrénaline toutes les longues pendant
ton nom de jours de tournage
après de philippe lety tombe malade
parce que l'équipe pour ça que ça
fonctionne parce que tout le monde est
sur ce big le que padar sûrs qu'ils t'en
fous qu'on ne peut de temps qu'on
hiroshi mais qu'on fait comme des
journées de fou puis tu portes là dedans
le ficus comme ça que tu réussi parce
que c'est moins chanceux j'ai été sur
des bons plateau en général je considère
m ais je mets 10 sur un plateau où
l'ambiance est polonaise je sais pas
comment tu fais pour survivre parce que
c'est vraiment un pc demandeur doit
dater plateau à dire cette adresse ouais
j'ai vraiment été chanceuse j'ai je suis
pas tombé sur des plateaux et guy comme
pas parler autour de toi des pâtes aux
plats et oui parce que c'est que nous
mais mieux classé que québec qu'en ne
portant pas d'argent donc ça fait que le
rythme de tournage et qui est difficile
c'est vraiment difficile et qu'on passe
si on se compare on se compare aux états
unis on se compare en france on se
compare aux mêmes au reste du canada les
ressources qui ont tout ce qu'ils
peuvent faire avec ce baisse est un peu
j'allais dire découragement n'est pas
décourageant parce qu'en fait on fait de
la très bonne voiture pour les
cadencements les budgets qu'on a pour
les pinèdes qu'on s'est vraiment pitt a
raison de le dire telle espèce d'esprit
2d qui plaide un projet nommé justement
tissu le film de pascale le sait tout le
monde fait 100% de son rôle
et puis même plus parce que parce que
tout le monde le fait est que si toi tu
le fais pas et canaux qui le faible tu
veux tu veux forcer autant pour pousser
le projet comment il s'est fait que
c'est sûr que tout le monde doit se
dépasser dans un contexte comme celui ci
les personnes qui comme vraiment assis
sur son exemple ça peut passer à tout
moment par l'ia y avait vendredi
petit a parlé des tournages les jours
des séries en france et groupe gipsy
comme cette photo gros gros éclairage le
gros tout le gros costumes gros budget
sur tout
puis j'en refais foule de teck votre nom
du temps parce qu'on a de l'argent
c'est comme quand tu t'habitues et déjà
d'avoir faim de faire deux textes parce
que c'est ce que ça prend pour ce qu'il
faut que ce soit comme on tue le temps
comme la contrainte fort sa sacoche
mais c'est certain qu'il ya énormément
de tournage américaines qui seront à
montréal au québec en jeu
ah bon la raison principale c'est parce
que c'est moins cher pour eux de ton ici
que tour nous mettons à new york et tout
témoin charlelie studio est la location
tout mais c'est aussi parce que ils sont
capables de reconnaître notre expertise
québécoise parce que leur petit même si
des preuves américaines s'avèrent des
techniciens québécois qui vont être
engagées qui sont toujours vraiment
impressionné les américains de voir
comme à quel point efficace
qui sait si je connais beaucoup de
techniciens qui travaillent sur des
projets américaine puisqu'il dit c'est
comme why cm sauf qu'est l'énergie puis
l'équipe c'est pas pareil dans l'épreuve
américaine télécom par département du
tout par le post monter l'équipe et maka
je veux pas parler à l'équipe son public
aux médias par justo comédie alors que
je pourrais pas imaginer un plateau
comme sow qui vexé su spots était ami
avec tout le monde pillet puis tu passes
ta journée avec mon honneur de
l'indirect le monde quand il finit la
journée de 12 heures et le goût d'aller
prendre une bière avec la gagne parce
que ça devient vraiment ta famille tu
vois plus ta famille pour ses clichés
l'on dit le tas comme on est une grande
famille mais messi sait c'est que ça
devient vraiment tu peux comprendre
c'est l'histoire tient kristen bell
avait avait sauté en notes contre les
gays qui s'occupait s'est passé c'était
carrément les acteurs fouet métiers
comme la proximité d'être dans le même
bateau que les autres personnes nanties
fait quoi alors que quatre des plus
proches comme et des mains comme fait
pas ceci vous plaît n'oubliez pas
l'espèce de déconnexion j'imagine
ouais exact puisque si le fait que tout
le monde est à l'aise avec les autres
parce que on est un petit milieu vêtir
croire sur ton prochain plan technique
c'est pis ça fait dix ans que tu
travailles avec la même gagne 1 à nice
on est vraiment des amis hors plateau je
pense que c'est ce qui fait la magie
c'est ce qui fait que même si des fois
les conditions sont difficiles
puis les gens gagnent ils sont une voir
leurs enfants perturbés on soutient on
mène le bateau à bon port parce que
sincèrement je trouve que
les gens qui travaillent dans ce milieu
c'est des gens passionnés à 100% mais
comme disait t'as pas le choix c'est
tellement un monde fou qui est pêcheur
d'être passé ni qui si t'aime pas fou le
seul fait de le technicien sonore
toujours pitt serait plus capable dans
la partie devait toutefois la fin et ça
dépend c'est quoi ton post ah ouais ben
on en a vu des exemples derrière les
enfants afin qu'ils gardent leur jet
paris chuté en haut de la pyramide plus
pauvres dans n'importe quoi je pense
qu'il ya comme le stéréotype que les
acteurs au city peuvent pas fin pour
autant nous avoir comme des caprices
mais je suis passé quoi aux états unis
tiji jamais tourné dans un film
américain mais au québec c'est pourtant
vrai comme le mot se passe vraiment
rapidement qui les gens veulent plus
travailler avec toi c'est vrai est gelée
vu j'ai vu ceux arrivés donc même en
tant que comédien
et même si on est vu comme m mais comme
intouchable des fois même à cette
affaire avait retraité ton équipe comme
dit mon kiki vraiment et qu'il
remplaçable au point petit qu il
nécessaire au point de dire que je peux
être un truc tu es tout le monde qui
vont pas rappeler personnes le temps ce
qui casse le pouvoir le sait il n'ya pas
de ne pas rater ce parfum j'ose espèrer
les personnes qui est un genre qui
écrasait qui sait pouvoir l'aider comme
il va devoir engager coûte que coûte une
chance bon j'avoue j'avoue que j'avoue
que brad pitt pour être un john surman
ce format il serait sûrement mais
peut-être ce serait pour toi est ce que
tu fais chier les gens de ce qu'est le
ring quand vous quand j'arrive sur un
plateau à parce que je suis garde car
apollo testbug à nantes
il faudrait leur demander même émotion
et je le dis avant le tournage est parce
qu il est de toute façon il demande tout
le temps allergies tbilissi l'isl de
tout le monde dans l'équipe cadet a
réagi fait manger dit que je suivais
galles et mais c'est de plus en plus est
mais commun est vraiment il y en a de
plus en plus j ai je veux dire quand
j'ai commencé
ça fait quand même longtemps que je fais
ce que je fais et puis quand j'ai
commencé il y avait même peux me tombe
d'options vg sur les prototypes
physiques en une collation pis c'était
se met maintenant c'est impensable ils
font tout en leur collation qui m mais
je reste quand même plus facile pour moi
invictus comédienne - c'est un peu la
partie plaquer un peu hiérarchique des
plateaux celle d'assistante technicien
lumière et va prendre une collation vgi
gens ça se peut qu'ils doivent enlever
sa maillot avec son petit couteau la
maison moi je le dis qui est 6e des
zones comme des privilèges de main en ce
que j'aime tellement peu cela ils en
chient sur les pertes sur ma jambe
gauche
mais messi c'est un avantage fait que ce
jeudi puis ça dépend le il ya des
cantonniers qui sont super ex tpiy voir
ces communes defeat les contenus web les
gens dit kraft mais s'essaye avec socom
extrait de faire plaisir tu es tu ne vas
faire découvrir des trucs qui en a qui
est bien ils l'ont pas pantoute la
bâtisse et c'est très gentil de leur
part un carte ni récemment j'ai dû est
il spécifié plusieurs fois qu'il ya des
oeufs
sam était bien moins plusieurs fois ci à
chaque fois c'était de la salade aux on
apprend que c'est quand même quelque
chose d'assez nouveau entre guillemets
meetic quand je lui mets ton 25 jours
sur un tournage puisque jour 23
on apprend en vrac en a pas
et la barre mais en même temps je me
sens tout simplement le tout un peu
comme face à leur demande plus de temps
pour tout m'était ses sous
je mange peu fake c'est soit exact il
faut que tu parce que les gens doivent
les gens doivent trouver qui est assez
fou un peu comme on naît de la
nourriture mais c'est parce que thomas
nicol qui l'on ne rit pas quasiment
personne qui est agent de remy va
t'apporter un bon sandwich mais nous
parce que on tourne des journées minimum
12 heures
en plus avec et la préparation les
matins si souvent 13 heures donc j'avais
c'est vraiment par étape fut bien le
dire tous deux comme mentionné aux gens
non se séparent vegan ceux ci peuvent
également comme ça a pris trois essais
que mon père de farouk et non l'autre
y'a du bio du board antarctique après
sur l'autre j'ai fait une soupe de
légumes crus
c'est quoi le bouillon que te prions
tous les risques la prochaine fois c'est
quand même le style ccdz le cantinier
mais au moins ça au moins ça change
parce que justement j'aime on en parlait
juste un petit peu avant nous on voulait
aller tester nos trucs vegan aux halles
a fait partie des gémeaux puis à 2 2
semaines d'hégémonie on avait comme pas
encore finalisé nos trucs que les autres
arrêtez pas décrire des images en rien
comme la fiq s'occuper de la gestion
intégrée des emails comment on a besoin
vos logos puis de vaud mepi de vos
affaires puis on n'avait pas ça de près
fait qu'on a juste écrit à écouter si ça
prend vraiment sur ben on peut pas venir
on vient de repos parce qu'on les a pas
fait claude hillion comme relayé
l'information jusqu'en haut
puis c'était tellement important pour
eux d'avoir une option vg
à ce parent telle qu'ils ont comme dit
aïe tchèque bolt en finale dans une
semaine qu'on a comme une semaine d'aidé
parce qu'ils voulaient vraiment insister
pour avoir les truck bus
waouh étonné ouais parce que c'est après
avoir acquis et que j'ai vu c'est dans
un acte brésil et qui est quand même
d'envergure et qu'une partie des jeunes
c'est vraiment gros
c'est une candidat yves citton se défait
de dire qu'ils allaient avoir je pense
qu'elle va avoir un genre de jouet pas
dans un parc comme un genre de 500 600
personnes way dans place puis une
avancée au hilton soultz ouais ouais les
tâches accomplies d'entendre les tâches
complet bord et d'un bond à bord il ya
des tables de service traiteur tout le
tour l'accueil qui circule partout par
open pour tout le monde qui rentrent le
billet quand tu vois où j'aime tout le
billet déjà de l'after 1000 billets
comme tel c'est un genre de 180 pièces
la rentrée le lycée pour le parti ouais
mais toi mes tongs dépôt éviter au gema
qui m'aimait mais c'est vraiment fun
mais c'est moi c'était comme sauvé la
vie parce qu'ils pensent que les jumeaux
le ca commence à genre 15 ou 16 ans et
parce qu'il ya les gars le pré prix
gémeaux gens qui me disaient à radio
canada mais qui comme son art et vie je
pense qu'ils aiment
nous on avait des prix on aime bien son
émission fait que je voulais y aller
toi te clément bg oui j'étais démener à
la soirée
piet ça finit ok tout ça dure où tout
avait pas de mener à l'abandon
peu importe le tout à l'heure pour tout
le long et ça finira comme on the path
absenté pendant le parent non mais parce
qu'anna qui me disait que des fois ya du
monde qui est un manga leur appartement
mais non tu peux pas ce que dit m
pete est allé se marier michaud et
j'espère le septième au fait que ma
blague tient pau wright est pas d'accord
non mais vraiment ils m'ont sauvé
parquet on devait arriver comme si on
était un oiseau non mais je faisais je
faisais tout les stand pl est restée
comme tard tort beaucoup de parents
réfléchissent et savoir plus je
regardais chercher des bonbons du htv
courage et qu'il est j'ai croisé mon
producteur en fait des leurres bleus y
veillant puis il dit tout du budget subi
ph le mexique je vais où sa partie fixe
à oued est revenue plusieurs fois pièces
que je pense que je faisais un manque
criant basque et j'allais dire à tout le
monde
non mais c'est vraiment bon c'est pas
juste une façon de tester notre uccle il
y avait cessé un enfant on avait dès ses
débuts
on avait des radios libres des
tortellinis de pâtes fraîches mais je
pense tu avais goûté une version des
déportés de nos fromages ne restait pas
cette version laisse de mer version plus
et là c'était vraiment débile mais
finalement c'est pas tout s'est produit
le qui ont vu le jour pour des raisons
de logistique qui était resté personne
mais on en aurait au casque bouchard
difficile on a sold out avant la fin de
notre chauffe excellemment
éventuellement à guetter l'espoir un peu
partout mais pour l'instant c'est tout
ce qu'on sait c'est gros comme on ne
tire pas en parler dans le fond on est
allé au cos côté puis on a fait une
annonce qu'on était le sait pour pour
présenter les plans puis avec eux les
primo kinky notre associé dans six
toiles qui nous épaulent un peu lutté
pour tout ce qui est entrepreneur lui
connaît faux kingsurf puis ça
l'intéresse se produit le fait qu'on
travaille avec lui puis on a fait un
poste avec lui puis dans dans le dans
les deux heures qui suivaient la
publication de tout il y aurait eu deux
appels de de l'équipe travaille chez mes
troubles et qui travaille chez ge qui
faisait que moi c'est quoi ce projet
comme on veut en entendre parler plus
parce que c'est débile at il dit donc là
on est comme sur plusieurs pistes de
messer c'est que du positif puis c'est
vraiment vraiment non mais je pense que
vous avez accompli quelque chose qui
existe est piqué c'est nécessaire pour
la cause des gars du québec - pastis a
fait connaître sa démocratie c'est ça
c'est ça la rend plus accessible sans
grand jeune et cool ouais c'est sale
c'est ça la fin c'est seul c'est ce
qu'on voulait faire c'est de rance au
jeune école pour poker tour de plus
mainstream qu'occupation double non
nathan a rien sur mesrine qu'occupation
double succès de farrar garmin stream
puis kalfon ce oui vraiment mais moi
j'écris là quand j'ai vu jesse quand
j'ai vu ça son portrait moi ça fait
combien de temps les clients et ça va
faire 4 ans cette race est coin à 4 ans
vj puis comme trois enseignants c'est
que lens est ce parce que ça fait
longtemps qu'on a pas parlé une digue en
dessous podcast
les motifs principaux lorsque tel moteur
mais en fait j'avais plusieurs amis
autour de moi qui étais vg que j'ai
commencé à être jugés en fait j'avais
plusieurs amis autour de moi qui étais
vgm qui à chaque fois on est je me
sentais comme coupable quand j'avais un
ami vigier avec moi est -ce qu'on allège
en tant qu'expression je me commandait
de pelé pire il commande et de fûts puis
à chaque fois jetés comme si j'ai pas
mal de bonnes raisons d eau ait eu leur
toit même réalisé c'est tuer ce que tu
as toi même tu t'es toi même mis en
perspective fait j'ai pas vraiment
raison bio qui en est qui des amis
végétaux tant parler non c'est plus moi
et eti la réflexion commencer puis une
fois que je me suis dit faudrait
peut-être amené dans ma vie je devienne
vigier le jeu leur marque est vraiment
plus tu es à chaque fois que je mange de
la viande comme le déclic c'est comme
sète puis j'ai pris la décision un peu
sur un coup de tête j'étais comme acquis
mois après le temps des fêtes et le 1er
janvier et suis j j'ai fait un peu ton
cerveau dans le mois de décembre 2018 le
jeu de novembre décembre pour moi je
vais être vg dans pau lons et puis le
jeu de l'alternance fin janvier j'ai
mangé mon véhicule puis après celui ci
est maintenant battant des frets est ce
que votre dernier dans des fonds être le
déclic s'est fait parce que c'était
comme je vois médecin off pour le hubei
cité genre les saucisses dans le bacon
et quand je veux aller manger une
dernière fois puis derrière good way
montcy step à marseille mais c'est drôle
parce que je m'étais dit ça faisait
comme des mois qui est déjà acquis le
1er janvier le 1er janvier le dise à
tout le monde promise en vie la mort de
mon team f1 comme apte à détroit lebron
j'étais premier les balles
seychelles et la tête mais pour moi ça a
été vraiment facile en fait je pense que
je t'aide comme dans les conditions
idéales pour faire c'est parce que je
n'ai de l'énergie chez mes parents et
que de toute façon j'en prenais à
cuisiner comme ce n'est pas quelque
chose qui était des jeux en moi et
raboté russie
j'apprenais en cuisine et je veux dire
comme les quelques mois et quand je suis
né sert avant d'être vigilants je
faisais brûlé mon poulet le dis comme je
ne savais pas comment cuisiner
donc de toute façon c'est comme elle ou
il fallait que je trouve quoi manger qui
en plus est japd en résidence qui ça a
donné que j'ai une coupe d'amis qui ont
comme fait le sweat en même temps que
moi c'est qu'on était trop fille et
qu'on s'est vraiment soutenu là dedans
puis ça a été tellement plus le fun
parce qu'on sait à la place que on
sentait pas en fait restreinte à la
place on sentait qu'on découvrait
quelque chose si on découvrait des
nouveaux rendement des nouvelles
recettes des livres des des vidéos
youtube tout ce qu'ils les trois en même
temps à un autre on a décidé de me
réveiller quand on est coupé comme
graduellement on est les produits les
tipis les opinions on s'encourageait là
dedans c'est que j'ai vraiment été comme
dans des conditions idéales qui est
encore maintenant ben ça m'a vraiment
rapproché de ses fils puis encore
maintenant comme celle effet avec qui je
branchais parce que je veux le serrer la
nourriture c'est tellement rassemblement
qu'est nous engueuler mentors canadiens
de prendre le temps de manger que les
gens oui les nouveaux ratios y en a eu
deux pages puis la première sur les
recommandations alimentaires la deuxième
c'est des recommandations d'habitudes de
vie
oui c'est d'apprendre de cuisiner entre
autres mais aussi de prendre le temps de
manger avec les gens c'est vraiment eu
le très bien dit ne se rassemblent en
fait que depuis s'est baissée s'essuyant
depuis je regrette pas cet été combien
de temps va t on à un an mais qu'elle
diminue graduellement testé comme marc
transition mais je me suis quand je
devenu végéter à tout le monde mais je
serais tellement jamais également
extrême
inquiet mais je pense que c'est parce
qu'il était la même manière qu'en ce
début j'ai eu des buts dit qu'il avait
difficilement ce compte là même en
acheter comme à qui je pourrais essayer
des femmes et à cause sans mettre des
fromages petit rencontre comme hawaï
c'est bon parler etc et c'est ce que
j'ai pas pu vraiment le avec aussi
l'arrivée de toutes les produits
disponibles en épicerie c'est comme
c'est vraiment facilité je veux dire les
canines fille qu'elle savait jouer 15
ans qui avait garé depuis comme comment
tu faisais à ce moment leur mari on y
prie puis dans les restaurants puis tout
cela alors que maintenant pour vrai je
trouve que c'est quand même un maxi
facile d'aller dans les restos tizi tt
vegan piste est comme le chef de bar qui
est passée cavale
qu'est ce que c'est pourquoi fort puis
s'est quand même qui a voté les romains
maison maison
mettez en admettant vgp vegan moss qui
le truc principal pour moi sur
l'environnement au delà des animaux delà
de ma santé c'est l'environnement tient
parce que ça décolle sur toutes les
listes
puis quand mes tantes utc de droit mais
c'est le lait c'est moins pire
puis le moine et j'ai fait mais au final
le lait faut quand même tu élèves des
vhc sont aussi polluante qu'un boeuf
s'est fait comme pour l'environnement
c'est pas mieux vaut mieux que manger un
steak maintenant fait kg je gomme katché
seul effet de moins dans le fond pour
cet argument là de l'environnement c'est
moins justifiables encore nommé mais
j'avais de vie des chiffres donnés
c'était comme acquis le niveau moyen
produite en démettant le mettons qu'on
parle de gs le producteur de gaz
carbonique un végétal avec en mai mais
n'ont fait capte tous deux tenu un petit
tas consommation de lipides au fouet
non non non puis j'attends des joueurs
on dirait que tiff c'est sur le cas des
gardes ça serait optimal
je sais mais on dirait que le jeu dans
une une pause parce que je me dis chaque
jeu contribué à ma façon
dans la manière du raisonnable pour moi
en ce moment choisi combo pierre camani
mais pour l'instant je suis bien à
chacun à son rythme mais j'ai encore le
fromage pilule du lendemain
non je vous je veux tous les genres et
pèse aujourd'hui journée devaient pas
boire mais dont est ce que tu penses que
tu buvais d'entendre les cagots
s'entraîner le dessus pas une journée où
est-ce qu'on s'entraîner mais mettons un
dimanche il n'y avait pas de trading
quantique devait autant de lait cadeaux
ou plus de la grippe au domaine saint
geneys buvait pas d'eau j'ai vaincu les
jets soit je me faire savoir délai
choisi le but est non mais les étudier
je vais occuper l'été je veux pas de
l'eau avec ma pizza lise genre direct
hong kong et si je voulais avec
n'importe quoi je vous fais ce genre
train de bouger
je crois en vendée les pousse à
rehausser les goûts
taiseux mais là aujourd'hui le litre de
lait
samedi 9
trois quatre jours ok c'est pas mal même
journée j'adore ce poids-là l'épicerie
aujourd'hui je veux acheter du lait
d'amande
une fois deux fois sur quatre l'aide à
la fois qu'il entend justement comme
coûté tantôt oui j'aime les blogs à la
bûche qui est en arrière là bas ah ouais
vraiment bah oui c'est du lait d'avoir
jamais c'est ça c'est du lait sans
savoir
mais non c'est sap il ya plein de les
plans d'options c'est plus en plus
faciles non c'est un peu ça qu'on
voulait faire tous nos produits de faire
quand même un petit peu juste aller
leurs pis c'est pas changé de ses
habitudes de file juste de faire la même
chose
appuie pleinement qui sont venus me voir
chercher la parade homme tantôt qui
écoute le parcage les salue d'ailleurs
qui me disait que grâce aux podcasts qui
avait commencé à faire attention à
réduire leur consommation qui était au
j'ai pas parlé d'être sublime succession
à gaza mais qui était venu parce que il
s'intéressait à sud depuis qu'ils
avaient commencé à écouter le podcast
c'est ouais j'aime ce fait des bonds pas
de casque avec jfc avec changé mais
quand même un spécimen alors que c'est
ta blonde qui te conviennent qu'ils
aillent des faces il sert à ce que les
blondes convaincre leur top et ça leur
est tout le temps mais aussi de rester
avec mon cinquième niveau encore m
escaré que je laime mais non mais
attendez mais
non mais dans le sens qui est un super
se jeter comme jessy qui ont passé
oui mais non mais c'est juste parce que
c'est non mais je sais moi je trouve que
c'est quand même gros mais en même temps
après je vois genre si j'ai des amis les
gammes qui vont dans des berlines deux
qui sont comme cultiver gang qu'il
convainque entre auxerre et clamecy
chacun d'imaginer gagnent trois mois ça
a commencé un peu de mal à od le jeu
vous dire j'ai quand j'estime à parler
c'est pour la première fois et je vais
pas faire comme automatiquement
j'adhère à tous qui étudie le très beau
début j'ai fait comme à quai pour ici à
od faire une offre le thé je vais pas de
manger du steak d'en face mais
maintenant je peux arrêter d'en manger
pour le temps que celui-ci truc après ça
je vais hériter puis la minute que j'ai
la chance de m'informer c'est comme ça
juste confirmer ce que j'avais déjà dit
je me sens encore bien j'avais aucune
lacune pie x qui nous manque ce que je
mangeais encore mais je cuisine beaucoup
je suis une encore piste encore
pratiquement fait j'avais aucune lacune
même informé ok faut que tu es convaincu
pour les bonnes raisons mais ton post
juste pour faire plaisir à l'autre mais
dictée vraiment convaincu pts informés
je pense que ceo de retourner à brême
parce que ben oui ces arguments sont
assez fort c'est nous autres on se
sépare d'un matin ouais c'est sûr mais
ça ça devient un peu aussi un mode de
vie ouais t'es tu remarques les choses
bien plus et j'ai petit monde m'attend
j'avais jamais remarqué à quel point on
voyait beaucoup de viande dans les pubs
moitié à l'atelier cinéma et dans les
magasins partout si j'avais jamais
remarqué à quel point peut-on voir la
viande crue
j'ai comme j'ai jamais pensé non ce
puits toutes les thématiques les jeux de
mots qui se font avec la ventiler nombre
des restos que ces gens là que ma grosse
truie chérie wes gentil des affaires
comme si même les pubs qui sait comme
et un poulet kg en ont même ne mange pas
passées comme acheter le boeuf de cochon
qui ont l'air bien content jean grey
swimmer lesquelles la banque autant se
faire manger le petit poucet comme non
les cochons contactez moi c'est quelque
chose que toi tu m'avais dit magpies que
subban et on avait été dans un groupe il
y avait ce monsieur post quand il y
avait des jambes des dessins d'animaux
de ferme et joyeux genre métier ça c'est
vraiment de se mettre la tête dans le
sable ces animaux si pour les bd les
condés fit un nom ont conduit ensemble
en revenant de la plage
oui puis ont conduit puis on fait juste
passer à côté d'un char d'un camion avec
un déport qui sortait lors leur museau
parlent parlent et parlent et routier
qui on est juste en silence on a dépassé
celle à qui on le fait c'est puis le
l'espèce juste l'espèce de up détourner
le regard c'est quelque chose que un
moment avant de rencontrer jesse avant
d'avoir l'espèce de switch qui se fait
dans ma façon de penser
en 25 ans vit jamais fait un joli cochon
ouais ouais ouais
météo les cochons il s'en vend même
s'ils s'en vont pas avoir d' iphone fait
comme l'espèce une fois de le déclic
effet puis j'en parlais justement avec
ma blonde hier c'est pas une question de
quand même c'est léa pleinement qui
écoute en ce moment qui concerne la
viande pis c'est ben querelles nicole il
doit consommer de la viande on le sait
ben correct laitiers se corse c'est
attaquer d'apollon il ya même un budget
porté comme dean mais non mais c'est ça
mais c'est parfait mais pourtant je
partais micka est excellent
paris s est en fait partie mais mais
c'est sa pitié cessez jamais touché
mêlée les cales des kyosai qu'ils soient
pas fait c'est juste de dire qu'il ya
vraiment quelque chose que souche et les
suffit qui sait ce titre toi c'est
suffit d'avoir un genre de doute
toujours de nouveaux regards sur une
habitude constructa eu ces taux
s'étaient quittés amis et manger vg je
vais m'engager à quitte ou double sens
pourquoi moi dans le fond choisi cette
option parce que pas un choix conscient
qu'on a fait de moi je la viande nantes
un choix imposé à nous d'être collectif
jugé comme une norme thé mais d'en
manquer qui te fais vraiment un choix
conscient de manger ceux où se mêlent la
question se pose peut être justement le
déclic s'est fait à une plus large
échelle de os contre ensemble un petit
bug à nice pour reprendre cette idée
l'aude de se poser des questions par
rapport à des idées préconçues qu'on a
qu'on fait juste vivre comme ça parce
que c'est comme ça jeudi un article
dernièrement dans le journal puisse été
repensé l'amour c'est sur les couples
ouvert puis même si tu n'avais pas un
couple ouvert mâché que ça serait pas
pour moi je serais pas capable de
fonctionner comme sauter sauf que de
reposer la question peut se dire est ce
que ça se peut qu'il y avait des
personnes qu'ils se soient correctes
pour eux puisque tout ce qu'on vit
depuis qu'on est tout petit de dire
qu'un divorce tuner chèque de dire que
un amas c est la pire trahison est ce
que tout ça est une conception qu'on
s'est fait donner ou dans lesquels on ne
grandit pas qu'on ne juge jamais
questionné même chose avec toutes les
cotes de genre maintenant c est ce que
c'est une conception qu'on a clairement
eu les genres biologique tu aimais des
sexe biologique mais ce que toute la
conception de qu'est ce qu'un homme
qu'est ce qu'une femme on a grandi non
sous le béton pour la monogamie
je dis clairement ce prix qui donne aux
jeunes par le sport aucune loi youri
c'est une construction sociale
si des juments ont décidé de s'organiser
majoritairement comme ceux ouais mais en
même temps surtout dans le passé les
chasseurs cueilleurs enlève le quarante
mille têtes monogame aujourd'hui gros
doutes là dessus j'ai les énormes aux
timbres amendes et autres couches et
quimper avec l'autre pied la manip ou
pas est un bébé qui vient de sortir
pourquoi je bossais non médecins les
chercheurs
neuf mois plus tard il y avait dit que
sort le très atlantiste acquis le pit et
ouais je sais c'est que premièrement
tout d'abord ce qu'il héritier du mais
j'avais lu que souvent justement c'est
tout le groupe qui élève les enfants
parce que super bon c'est bon c'est la
responsabilité de ce même quai je lisais
qu'il ya certaines civilisations
certaines tribus où je posais groupe que
plus mettons la femme même enceinte à
copuler avec différents partenaires là
c'était comme si ça redonnait la salle
arc genre ça rajoute edel
l'ensemencement qui était bon de se
piquer le bébé va être plus fort plus il
faut que tu aies fait qu'on dit ouah
c'est comme construire en qu'est la
science maintenant c'est que si une fois
que tu as qui raconte quelque chose ça
se passe mais comment savoir savoir
avant un possible mais tout ça pour dire
que effectivement de remettre en
question des trucs qu'on connaît depuis
tout le temps puis le véganisme c'est
exactement ce que ça fait quand tu poses
la question c'est que manqué quelque
chose de jeu de nouveau dans ma
perspective de voir les choses
une fois que tu as été quelque chose de
nouveau tout tout autour de nous est
issu pratiquement l'exploitation animale
c'est beaucoup le ca réalisé tout seuls
et ils l'ont on voit jeu pas encore les
la compagnie vraiment qu'on la voit pas
caméra métis une crème de beauté
je vous garantis que cette crème de
beauté lorsque je connais la marque est
testé sur les animaux c'est fake comme
en ce moment il ya des animaux
on pense que ça existe plus encore très
mauvais mais doivent être votées fois
quant à quentin mais c'est drôle que tu
dis parce que ça me fait penser à quand
j'ai eu mon éveil féministe parce que
dit quand j'ai commencé à comprendre qui
s'était pas calmée qu'est ce que ça veut
dire se dit à quel point le sexisme est
partout et je voyais jeu se voit imputer
pendant une période ça m'a rendu comme
misérable par ce que j'ai déjà tout ce
que je faisais de ma journée je le
remarque et à toutes les tables de
maddie partout autour de moi et même sur
les réseaux sociaux j'avais l'impression
qu'elle comme bombay soudainement je
vois qu'ici partout et métis parce que
c'est avec le temps je n'étais pas seul
et veille à une nouvelle cause ou aux
nouvelles problématiques sociales c'est
comme le tabac partout dit obsédé par ça
ce qui fait que des fossiles livre de
groupes universitaires soient féminines
et ce militant général de foot c'est
comme trop c'est parce que c'est comme
la nouvelle cause que l'on s'intéresse
plus on apprend ce club si on le voit
partout manning justement avec la joue
avec l'état tous deux viennent tramo
l'ipo meti a banni ce parce que le ta
qualité de ville puis genre sentimental
amené food s'entendent de l'activisme
durable moi c'est ce site offre imagine
ce sont les deux seules villes puis on
va revenir à cause féministe après parce
que parce que ça m'intéresse beaucoup
mais juste 10 ou par rapport aux
véganisme imagine venir avec la fibre
que tu es entouré de meurtriers de masse
tout petit nom est que devant un party
de noël
tu as envie de pleurer à chaque fois
plus frappées de famine en phase
possible
faut que tu fermes année vous faire mal
rideau les déconnectent faust accepte le
fait qu' il ya une limite d'alcool du
plus âgé au pied qui l'a pas saisie
si pour tout avoir un animal c'est un
meurtre dans l'absolu qui met souhaiter
bonne fête à port la manière mais par
rapport justement à cause féministe ma
blonde qui s'impliquent quand même
beaucoup à ce niveau là
si on a plusieurs meetings ensemble que
ce soit pour pour pour la bouffe c'est
pour notre site web
puis on me fait remarquer constamment
comme la première fois que ça arrive et
on avait un meeting l'annonceur du
meeting pour a fait remarquer à qui on
s'adressait que je dis que non tout le
monde avait une conversation étaient
autour de la table on avait une
conversation turquie c'est la prochaine
fois qu'on se retrouverait que ces gens
le remarquent à qui on s'adresse qu'un
comparé la jeci ph prochain mi temps on
arrive en 8ème tous les regards sont
verts - les questions me sont adressés à
moins qu'un l'yonne remarque qui équipa
en ligne avec notre pensée comme une
méthode à jesse pea - sévère - qu'on
sait moi qu'on interroge t elle que je
remarque ça au deuxième mi temps que le
sort du meeting
théo facile tu me disais qu'un léger
porte attention j'ai remarqué un diwan
dit mais c'est comme ça à chaque fois
qu'on a invité à chaque fois qu'on sera
encore pire dans tout ça c'est surtout
par rapport à des trucs qui ont un lien
que le véganisme si je dois aller
beaucoup plus d'expérience que moi c'est
moi si quelque chose doit juste répéter
ce qu'on en discute ensemble
c'est sûr que le monde vont écouter
parce que ça vient de moins de 15 ans
quand j'ai vu ça les fait tabarnak
c'est vrai que c'est sorti plus près sa
séquence a remarqué d'un email c'est
comme christ lui même c'est pas
salut gc ph c'est comme ça lui ph
voici les informations c'est comme une
vieille garde londres avec des gens qui
sont plus jeunes ou qui ont peut-être
pas puis c'est pas mal intentionnés jeu
persuadé que c'est pas par manque de
respect ou par désir de d'attribuer plus
d'attention et warneton les séparent
habitude kassim que cette année c'est
toi qui lis piqué c'est toi qui prends
les décisions business et marketing qui
tout se passe que parce que comment ça
pourrait être une femme qui est à la
tête de ce type sont idiots puis c'est
peut-être même pas c'était même pas la
réflexion qui se passe non non je pense
pas ça existe c'est là qu'il est mais
honnêtement puis je pensais pas que
c'était aussi évidente et moi je me dis
allez à 1 et comme je comprends le mais
on vit dans une société qui s'en vient
vers l'égalité à le disséquer réclament
et de tabarnak est quelque chose de plus
systémique non dans tout seul mais c'est
certain que ce problème est qu'il existe
cette dynamique là où on accorde peu de
crédibilité à le discours masculins que
féminins y existe j'en suis convaincu
mais dans ce cas précis la cessoie
présent aussi mais sûrement d'autres
facteurs qui rentrent en ligne de compte
premièrement le fait que tu es un leader
naturel
ouais mais sa situation tu te retrouves
tu vas prendre le lead pouvoir qui
pratiquent des limites et se prenaient
plus de place alors les plus le terrain
j'étais plus de temps mais que les
emails s'adresse à toi parce que c'est
plus souvent tout qui répondent tous et
en tant qu'étranger avec les autres fuck
is aussi vraiment pitié moi mettons les
moments c'est vite arrivé car avec mon
ex les honneurs des meetings ont eu
ensemble politique mais c'était souvent
plus elle quitta en bolide un ca de
ressources souvent elle qui vous
adressez à moi c'était clair qu'elle
soit parce que c'est une amie qui
mettons elle est l'artiste puis moi je
suis le réalisateur ou le leti legault
qui a su porte avec sedan mardi
l'imam a ou on s'adressait à moi puis on
n'aurait pas dû puis j'avais s'inverser
puisque la castille mettons on arrête on
devrait s'adresser à liane 10 par mois
vous ne répondez pas parler pour ben
jawad il y en a dans ce sens que la
question devrait à tous afin que vos
histoires et pour moi c'est aussi
d'apprendre à laisser la place bah oui
mais exactement absence parce que moi je
moi je me disais si naïvement on pose
une question je réponds tu es puis une
fois que jusqu'à maintenant c'est ce que
je fais c'est que marquez vous poser une
question en disant clairement je suis
prêt qualifie que c'est que tu réponds
jarbou qui s'est passé le micro au pied
qui prend 2,2 toi ton privilège pile à
ce que les gens et accorde naturellement
qui dépote
mais entre que c'est vraiment
intéressant de réfléchir ce truc-là de
com réalisé qu il faut qu on est dans
une société qui est vraiment qu'il ya
des défauts de c'est qu'il faut les
comprendre qu'il faut aussi d ajuster
sans aller overboard d'un côté mais ce
risque là est très faible
d'un côté ces personnes peuvent aller au
bout mais là ce que la société allait
nom maintenant c'est moi mais c'est déjà
quelque chose avant ni qu'ils aient
comme et système blanc gris qui disait
comme à l'ism sont chanceux qu'on veut
juste l'égalité picon veulent pas la
revanche c'est vrai deal comme que les
femmes prennent plus de place ça ça vaut
pas enlever rien il nous a dit je
m'essaye quand on parlait beaucoup de
parité en politique puis tout ce que les
gens disaient comme ça veut dire qu'il
ya des hommes devront se faire tancer
qui vont perdre des jobs est ce parce
que s'ils perdent leur job sur ce qu'ils
méritent pas d'être lus en com
d'abord tu es si on veut comme un
système qui paritaire
je dirai à personne qui va donner des
jobs juste pour le fun qui veut comme
surtout maintenant en politique l'était
des jobs qui sont importantes comme
genre on va se faire soit par des
incompétents comme n'y a personne qui
veuille ce qui je veux dire une demande
moindre liste d'incompétente je vais en
écrire qu'au niveau des écrans touche
également des compétences et une coupe
des coupes et je vais aller jeu quand je
veux qu'on coach de là mais je vais
chercher nos gammes visite je suis
quelque chose doit d'abord moi je viens
d'apprendre à l'ensemble mais tant qu'on
parle bien de finir le tournage avec
l'or bleu l'arb le web si on est fini
notre blog qui va nous rester une cette
saison une comme comme une mini ça il
aura plus de dix épisodes pour boucler
la boucle
et puis après bien s'arrêter c'est fini
c'est fini pileux il était beau projet
c'est en parler peut pas parler
non pas tant que ces annonces et ben oui
mais je dirais que c'est la vie depuis
gestion fait que céder ou et des bas je
suis pas dans les années le plus occupé
de ma carrière mais ça va bien je
pourrai plus en plus au jeu mais tant
qu'on fera corps parce que le ph saisis
on va considérer le féminisme sms qui
est béton parce que sur des plateaux ou
dans des tentes au milieu de travail
trop injuste
ou est ce que c'est un milieu qui est
assez avancé sur sa plage est un milieu
sain milieu très masculin les pieds
c'est vraiment intéressant j'avais lu
une étude qui a été faite en france sur
les postes qu'occupent les femmes dans
le milieu mais sur des plateaux de
tournage qui s'est beaucoup de postes
m et d'assistance ou de support en natif
et par exemple à donner l'exemple et des
scripts qui sont presque entièrement
féminin et j - personnellement j'ai
jamais rencontré du script était pas de
femmes effectivement un métier qui
traditionnellement féminins
je sais pas pourquoi la base mais ce que
ce que l'issue des 10 aces et etc est en
fait la script est assise à côté du
réalisateur général saint brieuc attend
et il veut vraiment à être son support
pour tout être comme sa main droite
donc c'est la personne qui organisait la
personne et qui sait où est ce qu'on
s'en veut et la personne aussi qu'il
recueille toutes les confidences du
réalisateur et donc qui sert un peu de
support moral de sport émotif à son
réalisateur puis on a souvent un lit
souvent le premier instant 21h mais de
zemma standard est une fille parce que
c'est elle qui fait la logistique mais
cnppo qui veut pas gérer le plateau mais
qui fait la logistique
bon c'est sûr que ça s'équilibre de plus
en plus dense sur la pathologie était
l'emblème nos deux chefs machine aux et
des fils apprend qu'il va sauter et puis
il ya de plus en plus réalisatrice pis
tant mieux
mais c'est sûr que c'est un cinematic
soins qui sont traditionnellement et
masculins même mais même en tant
qu'actrice
oui on a l'impression qu'il y ait autant
de comédienne que des comédiens et sauf
que si on regarde les statistiques au
niveau des rôles et par lee et l'ism
parle vraiment plus que les femmes et
puis elle a rôle en général plus de plus
de contenus plus devient mais comme on
dit c'est pas de la scripte mon frère
maquilleuse c'est comme les psychologues
des plateaux et michael bay jeudi
automatiquement les maquilleuses parce
qu'il est métisse je pose les
maquillages parce que c'est drôle parce
que souvent m
ils vont se faire rappeler et tu mets
ton chef coiffeur chef maquilleur qu'il
a fait
la maquilleuse c'est un oui non mais tu
sais que vu un peu comme du fleuve
rapide ailleurs c'est les départements
qui se font couper le plus rapidement md
qu'on a pas de budget dans un film et
ont un projet vraiment à l'aube au jet
li et ça va être mauvais les acteurs
allez vous confirme m
parce que c'est quand même super ciel et
tout ce qui est statisme coiffure
maquillage alors que je veux dire on en
a vu des films et des séries que ça
apporte un cake ça raconte une histoire
puis ça ça apporte une autre couleur aux
personnages du jeu des rentes que c'est
essentiel je veux dire les maquilleuses
il faut pas juste comme nous met
mascaret y travaille la lumière dans un
visage qui vont adapter selon l'angle de
la caméra puis selon le lieu ton âge
indices y ans le été si fascinant et qui
est pourquoi ces missiles sont
considérés comme points importants
souvent quand on ne peut de temps sur un
partout c'est comme on fait pas de
retouches mais jamais ça va être comme
on en fait peu d'ajustements lumière du
rpt c'est surtout que ces gens là mais
c'est en plus de leur travail qu'ils
font très bien c'est un contact humain
que vous avez
j'étais avec quelqu'un qui comme acquis
quatre journées ce ton plateau mais au
moins la personne qui tenait à qui tu
peux en parler d'esprit mais oui
clairement c'est avec eux qu'il commence
sa journée à la base je veux pas été
choqué après basta donne le ton en fait
je trouve que ça donne le ton ou un mi
journée qu'un 4 tu tu utilises tu étais
réseaux sociaux pour parler de toutes
ces choses là c'est quoi les réactions
sur soi du monde issue parce que les
gens qui t'ont connu qui connaissent mes
tongs pour taqa rédactrice de suivent
mais t'es tu as quand même assez vocal
sur les réseaux sociaux pour prendre
cause c'est quoi la réception de ton
public quand il traite de tout c'est
parce que parce que j'ai beaucoup
d'influencés rock influences comme toi
mais en général j'ai des réponses quand
même assez positive et parce que je
pense qu'il ya un filtre qui se fait
automatiquement religion qui me trouve
que son voeu de voir dans l'espace mais
jusque là les autres mamies se
désabonnent ou baillet ils vont s'amener
à d'autres j'en ai fait que ses
collègues parce que j'ai pomme non plus
ces gens là mais des sceptiques comme un
filtre naturel qui fait et fait ce que
j'ai trouvé difficile pendant le moment
ça se place un peu mais c'est que
j'avais beaucoup d'abonnés qui était
très jeune
j'en ai encore mais étant donné que
régis fait des émissions jeunesse les
films ambitieux j'aime et qui me
suivaient pour ce que mon travail en
tant que maintiennent tant que je
trouvais ça difficile d'interagir avec
mes abonnés par ce qui est comme neuf
ans non mais c'est génial pour pleine
affaire du pouce aux féministes leur
projet polar
j'avais pas la réception que je
souhaitais aimé
elle ça se passe tranquillement puis je
pense que dorénavant ya des gens qui me
suivent pour ce en se disant bombay
peut-être qu'on va avoir un point de vue
un peu différent et avec alex pic qui
veut pas nous parler des mêmes choses et
piment c'est pour ça que tu sais que
j'ai parti manche une utopie c'est pour
ce qui est que je veux dire il ya bien
des fois c'est comme je pense vraiment
pas beaucoup sur les réseaux sociaux
genre un terrain tout comme je suis
vraiment pourtant active
je pourrais elle ait plus le dis comme
bien des fois dans ma journée où je
pourrais certainement celle picardie
stories qui ait vraiment une bonne puis
je le fais pas parce qu'ils et pour
plein de raisons mais surtout parce que
je sais qu'il ya un an mais se voit
tellement d'affaires que c'est comme si
tu le vois pupilles et coup de pub y
entrer que j'ai le goût de parler quand
je trouve ça important puits pour peu
que les gens y est en aussi parce que je
pourrais le jeu des fêtes et markov sur
des enjeux et qui met hors de moi tous
les jours comme je le fais tous les
jours dans ma vraie vie vraie passé sur
les réseaux sociaux et j'essaie de doser
way avec make up c'est bien fait par
exemple pickas et fait le trou sur un
ton moralisateur maintenant informatif
c'est maintenant je pense à des gars
comme aimait le voit par exemple c'est
super bon ses fans informatif pitre où
ça mais c'est quelqu'un qui utilise sa
tribune pour enfin quelque chose comme
ça mais c'est justement maintenant jeter
ton dernier vidéo c'est que ces mêmes et
on met dix coups de coeur mais je trouve
ça le fun pareil que tu sais le format
habituel qu'on connaît de genre la fille
ce plan devant sa caméra dans ce
championnat mais tu parles des musiques
par le théâtre parle de tout les trucs
que tu aimes tu es de cinéma puis c'est
comme ça de l'hôpital good ali d'être
curieux tout le goût d'apprendre nouveau
avant tout le goût d'aller tchéquie
c'était le goût de l'auteur d' ccc c'est
cool moi moi je trouve ça plus
intéressant que dire que mes dix coups
de coeur c'était le bikini dechy telle
place picasso matisse je pose du jury
non merci mais c'est gentil parce que si
ceux ci se sont vus
si je n'aimais prat voodoo sur ma chaîne
ce qui me fait un peu connaître sur
youtube c'est que j'avais fait une vidéo
je me maquillais mais tout le long je
parle de notre club c'est bon ce test là
c'est comme le summum du clic bay away
je vous amis ici mais j'ai quelque chose
que vous avez vous savez pas mais je lis
pas caché le monde titre si je manquais
pige aux des politiques d c'est peu
c'est pas un secret mais si ta routine
beauté
est-ce que tu expliques que se présenta
face non mais j'en parle un peu parce
qu'ils aient en février passé c'est
drôle parce que à ce moment là j'avais
même peu de temps pensé à ma stratégie
bien mon concept tout les jantes et
comme mike au site tellement eu une
bonne bij que mais n'ont pas vraiment
fait parce que je veux marquer pour moi
fight puis jetée comme j'ai fait un luxe
à ma chaîne youtube mais c'était jean le
jour après que deux notions pas été élu
puis georges pouvait pas passer à autre
chose c'est que c'était juste comme à
québec je vais faire les deux en même
temps tu es gens parler voilà la passe
de faire des vidéos pièce a marché et
fait qu'il ne serait plus le concept
genre et si les bikini bikini aux
accords à barlin le guen va peut-être
les bikinis bah oui s'impliquer dans la
campagne provinciale le 2 août avec
comme tu avais suivi
si jal a plus qu'à chaque fois que j'en
pense comme vous je sors du papillon et
web et sté générale mais moi je suis
mais c'est intéressant la politique
depuis mon plus jeune âge j'avais 8 ans
pied le 21 mai j'avais 8 ans piège
couvrait les élections américaines
non pour ouvrir le lard génération le cd
en tartan ça fait plusieurs fois qu'on
se passe les commentaires c'est on earth
day on earth eu entre autres et surtout
les acteurs mais attendez lippi landeau
décoré longue après sophie nélisse un
capotage on capote en ce moment on ne
grandit vite et les acteurs se seraient
des bibittes particulière est entouré
d'adultes souffrent est entouré
d'adultes depuis qu'on est jeune pions
se fait demander d'agir on adultes avons
des responsabilités d'adultes de
commander ton discours y suit aussi les
deux pôles choix d'école puis vous êtes
appelés à la lumière de vous même tout
le temps peur vous dépensez je pense que
c'est mon truc
ouais de son mouvement mais c'est gentil
mais non mais pour ma part j'ai quand
même grandi dans une famille militante
en général mes deux parents sont
artistes est qui et qui ont toujours été
et et marées elle se fait traiter de
dire annuler parce que le gars doux nom
de grand messe à tirano le réseau c'est
l'autre niveau n'était pas déjà noté
tanguay habituel mais oui c'est un
effectif c'est toujours comme ça a été
vraiment encourager chez moi de parler
politique si ce n'est pas comme on peut
faire une politique à table au contrat
qui genre ont été encouragés sur la base
ennemie question oui pareil me disait on
parle jamais de qui on vote non pas au
contraire on parle d'eux qu'ils ont mais
c'est très québécois signe comme un
adage de genre et aux à table on parle
pas de politique de religion vie
d'argent puisque tu veux qu'on en parle
ou non mais c'est vrai dit tu peux pas
en parler en famille tu peux pas en
parler au bureau et en parle quand on
pense qu'à québec
oui non la malheureuse mais pourquoi pas
non mais ça veut juste avec des
discussions des bonnes discussions pour
amener à
à fin de journée on peut être d'accord
et en désacord s'occupe t combat après
avoir appris les deux mois je pensais
moi je pensais que mon père était
fédéraliste jusqu'à 20 carnet on a une
conversation à ce que je fais rendu un
adulte puis que je parlais de comment
moi si un référendum je voterai pour la
séparation qui me dit il me dit la
première fois que j'apprends si j'ai
quand même trois ans il y avait sa carte
du pq qui va te dire voter oui aux deux
à west diège porte était de la liste non
mais moi comme moi c'est juste comme on
dirait que je pensais surtout aucune
raison mais parce que tu avais jamais eu
ces discussions ces dommages pourraient
faire grève et non mais moi j'étais
j'étais vraiment chanceux c'est d'un thé
lui dans une famille comme ceux qui
aiment fait qu'ils effectuent ce je me
suis toujours est intéressé à la
politique je pense que comme pas aider
les gens mon déclic s'est vraiment faite
en 2012 avec la grève était mon père
était enseignant à l'université
m'asseoir et et le cégep avec ma famille
j'étais comme aline et j'ai cassé mon
album moi j'étais en secondaire 3 et
mais j'étais dans ce décret vraiment
impliqué george allen mais des autobus
jusqu'au magnifique en italie ou en
effet deux journées de grèves et de
piquetage puis tout ces petits pour
n'est que secondaire séquence mélange
par une chance mais tu te monte en
bourse à l'école ouais on n'est fait
invité jusqu'à présent 22 gates a
pourtant 98 pour sa commune jokela
d'armand meiway médecine école du mile
end tapinoma les 2% ce qui s'est passé
qui perd les pièces et se fait qu'ils
soient vraiment été comme on y veille ad
militantisme et de l'éveil de beaucoup
de gens a tellement menti chanceuse je
trouve que je suis chanceuse d'avoir
vécu c'est à l'âge que j'avais parce que
j'y peux étais tu veux dire ma soeur
pour elle aussi c'est comme un événement
marquant dans sa vie mais de nos nerfs
elle a été un peu traumatisés gens parce
que été dans les premières lignes
oui j écoute ma soeur continuer de
militantes mais ça a été une
rêve vraiment difficile pour elle puis
comme plein de monde dans sa courte sont
comme quasiment tombé en dépression
après la grève parce qu'ils étaient
comme on ne put que j'en sais plus quoi
faire avec large face à l es 26 hockey
dont l'anglais qui nous a écrit que
c'est comme si comme s'ils avaient
laissé sa vie complète white collar si
gabrielat doute bout et on a parlé d'
atypique avait réalisé s'étaient
dissipées on a travaillé fort mais on a
gagné
ouais les gars qui écrit sinon rien
il dit y a du monde de demain qui ont
été brisés par ce biais du monde qui ont
requis ont tout donné qui ont délaissé
leur santé physique vers santé mentale
puis le guet legault parlait t on dirait
qu'il revenait de la gare andré qui
revenait de dames le titre est
clairement post traumatique le des
quelque chose le team et luise sayah
vais rentrer dedans puis il lui est aux
personnes infectées d'autres mutine où
je l'aï vécu à distance ac et au multaq
a b c ont été agréable goûter en musique
adversité enfin l'option d'un rouge mais
j'ai pas fait tabasser par ses deux
usines mais si c'est fait que tu es
chanceuse d'avoir vécu de l'extérieur
parce que ça me jusque 2 x 1 un projet
et d'avenir puisqu'elle c'est possible
de se mobiliser puis de changer les
choses
donc et à ce moment là pour moi il ya
tué susi qualité comme un peu une
révélation menti je pense pas que ça
reste secret pour personne que celle aux
fruits qu il faudrait connaître mais
c'est vrai qu'après 2012 y ait une
espèce de vide de gens qui disent que le
projet m'a présenté le projet phone est
un mouvement
on s'est tous serré coût d'ensemble pile
ça serait le fun on avait on avait suivi
des gens somme toute charismatique qui a
manqué au québec de rihanna ou
mouvements ce qui manque aux quais au
québec gravement depuis depuis aussi
longtemps que je me souvienne d'eux des
échos que j'entends du monde qui était
le dernier prophète saw 6 rené lévesque
oui à avoir soulevé un charisme qui
donne envie de suivre cette personne moi
celui qui le le mieux et le plus fait
moi sans doute livre
mais ce sera en 2012 tient en 2011 les
eaux calmes même que léo est également
plus charismatiques gamme à ce moment là
haut de gamme était plus radicale dans
son oeuvre ont l'opinion peut plus là -
ouais je pense que pour eux pour la
majorité des étudiants qui étaient en
grève étaient ils voulaient sur les
recettes
c'est comme ce radicalisme à quel point
c'est que cette instance de vraiment de
changer le sas copie tout ça mais après
tout ce que je me suis encore plus
intéressant à politique qui est j'ai
toujours dit que ce n'est pas prêt à
suivre et gabriel de loin dans ce qui
faisait j'ai dû cesser ses petits amis
et je les rencontrer dans une première
des films en fait et dans la première le
film de m
[Musique]
pisi citer qu'elles financent l'équipe
de cu huy ha vu que j'avais mis cette
photo les faits qui m'ont contacté et on
dit s attendent sud et venir passer une
journée à l'assemblée nationale puis
comme un cui et 6 4 avec us ou peugeot
comme j'aurais dit oui à l'assemblée
nationale juste parce que j'étais
curieuse
donc j'ai rencontré l'équipe j'ai adoré
ma journée
puis ils m'ont recontacté pour la
campagne électorale que j'allais passer
trois jours complets en campagne avec
eux et que c'est génial parce que j'ai
pu voir un peu tout et j'ai vu et
commence à se penser comme au quartier
général à montréal puis après on est
parti à québec qui et comment il
essayait vraiment de gagner des leaders
les deux circonscriptions label qui
s'était peu gagné d'avancé
c'était vraiment c'est que mes devoirs
le travail de cette petite équipe le dis
maintenant il ya dix députés donc sont
vraiment plus grosse gang mais je dirais
quand j'allais à la cent mille installé
à lyon il y avait comme les bureaux du
fond du couloir il était jean cys c'est
comme read c'est fou de penser que c'est
juste 7 gagne le qui fait ce petit
souvent je pense qu'on regarde la
politique la politique qui ont ni comme
un peu cynique dans l'école qui crie
vers disco
pour pierre il pense même pas ce qu'il
dit c'est que c'est la gazette mais non
mais c'est fou tipi mais c'est moi c'est
ce qui m'a impressionné c'est d'avoir le
le travail de ces gens là qui met le
travail des députés
charlie en commission parlementaire avec
gabriel c'est vraiment comme ça on a le
mental on n'entend jamais parler de ce t
on ce qu'on voit c'est la période des
questions
quand ils s'envoient chez un petit peu
mais la majorité de la grande partie du
travail des députés sont commission
parlementaire
c'est le quai ils travaillent les lois
même genre comment notre société était
ou est ce que ça s'enligne puis les
chiens seraient la réforme des normes du
travail
c'est big quand même qu'ils aiment jeudi
les six ans comme parlementaire c'est
qu'ils vont regarder comme chaque ligne
chaque mode projet de loi qui les lie
les parties de poissons peuvent proposer
des amendements
puis c'est le tu vois à quoi ça sert des
partis d'opposition qui veut dire y ont
beau pour avoir tenté sa chance à ce
moment là il y avait deux sièges
m je veux dire qu'à briller le nombre de
fois qu'il veut vraiment inquiété comme
moi j'veux pas d'accord je veux qu'on
ajoute t'elle claus pis si je pense que
ça devrait passer une vie libre puis je
veux dire en général ça marche tu es en
général ils écoutent les amendements qui
font comme ok puis tout le monde
travaille ensemble puis c'est ce qui est
beau aussi je veux dire yannick docquier
à l'assemblée nationale les genres
toutes les villes vite et je me semble
peu importe les partis politiques qui
quand ils se croisent dans les couloirs
on se salue puis c'est comme sont toutes
body body fait que moi ça m'a vraiment
comme m
ben j'ai fait la paix avec la de voir ça
de l'intérieur s'était rendu moins
cynique qui sert à des gens de bonne foi
qui travaille pour totalement je sais
pas si j'aurais eu la même conclusion et
avoir passé une journée avec le parti
libéral mais reste que de voir
les députés qui dédient leur bia seul il
pense que quatre jours par semaine à
l'assemblée nationale les trois autres
jours ils sont bons à recompter 10
règles genre madame chose qui veut pas
une grèce apportées rouge paient
non mais si kezman job c'est la
caricature maintenant game of thrones
l'ouest comme de l'art web de tout le
monde qui passe en a un
oui revendiquer leur est chipé sa qualif
mais si c'est vrai en ce que fait que
j'y trouvais leur travail vraiment
impressionnant donc après deux ils
suivent en campagne c'est aussi c'était
comme une autre affaire de voir m le
projet qui porte que c'est pas juste
on veut gagner tant de sièges pour qu
elle piqué - tiens ici pas pantoute ceux
qui comme on veut parler au monde pis
pour eux qu'on travaille plus on est
allé dans une banque alimentaire je vais
voir mon nom le servir la bouffe aux
gens qui parlaient aux gens qui à quel
point elle parle le même langage qu'eux
en pis elle est connue qui est à leur
demande c'est comment la même entrecôte
de voir ce côté humain le de la
politique
plus jamais je vais genre douter m des
bonnes intentions des politiciens qui
n'en seraient pas ce qu'ils sont là pour
les bonnes raisons
la faute à sa main je pense que la
majorité c'est trop travailler pour être
le rôle de député de la cac
ouais ouais ouais je comprends c'est
difficile et a fait 10 c si tu veux du
pouvoir de l'argent et du pouvoir
toutefois n'avoir l'homme est fait de
l'argent qui la couler douce tepa bonne
place moi je pense la grande majorité
sont là pour les bonnes raisons
après ça une fois qu'ils étaient là faut
que tout pouvoir
l'eau c'est peut-être là que ça se gâte
quand tu touches ou pivot au pouvoir
4 toucher aux avantages pillot vous
intéresse pas voir le site le pouvoir
corrompt monde sait ce qu'on veut je
pense que je pense que je passe quelque
chose de réel c'est donc ça c'est
certain si santé mais mais
c'est déjà je pense que l'important
parti si tu vas voir des gens vraiment
dévoués qu'ils font qu'ils sont là pour
les mêmes raisons mais qui ont une
différence c'est que la bonne façon de
le faire exactement c'est vraiment ce
web totalement puis j'ai trouvé ses
impressions j'ai trouvé ce beau de voir
quel point ces sociétés comme dévoués à
leur cause peu importe c'est quoi leur
côté m
je veux dire j'ai clairement pas
d'accord avec les idées de tous les
partis sont la famille nationale mais
est-ce que leur travail est colossal
puisque quand on se met ensemble je
demande on est comme ça parlementaire il
ya quand même cédé 0,20 juste avancer la
société soit adopté
c'est que comme tout le monde est
d'accord qui met sa voiture pour le
québec n go et provenait ramadan est
venu ici léa clermont dion avait pas de
caspian a tourné déjà plusieurs sans
voix sorti un sac marron puis bon bah
non avenu cité alors l'après-midi les a
fait et fera de mal en pis d'une d'une
humanité tu peux pas fait qu'un seul nom
minutieusement des cons certains jeux
lego georges lecteurs comme tous les
côtés étaient sur l'ordi à l'arrivée si
près herment a dit bonjour attaquants
d'entrée des yeux qui a serré dans ses
bras sur le goût de la prime à man le
direct est le goujat
finalement son affection le genre pour
pau pour les gens pour les autres le nez
tu le sens ce que c'est un épicier à la
raconter sa vie à pleurer sur le podcast
avec les autres c'est comme d'une
humanité le pit est de réussir à rester
aussi aussi grande et que ce puits aussi
proche du vrai comme ce malgré justement
des fois je te marier
il y aurait promis maty sarr et devenir
cynique dans son travail parce que tu
sais ça fait longtemps qu à face aux
défauts optiques à 45 ans les choses
changent pas à l'éviter ce qu'elle
voudrait ou attrape auquel le pouvoir
qu'a cac qui est ce qu'ils risquent
cependant l'opposition petits peuvent
pas il ya plein de choses qui se
décident qui sont en désaccord le théme
elle a contenu puis l e pour le monde
puis pour vrai que ce soit pro ou que
quelques us à tanger en coupant toute
cette fable à une rolls quelques temps
sa présence qui est magnifique c'est
ouais ouais vraiment ils m'ont tellement
fait sentais comme si j'étais chez nous
le cerveau humain non mais vraiment et
petit comme je rentrais dans la récup
c'est une équipe qui était surtout en
campagne électorale le ticket des supers
soudé puis moi j'arrivais le pour créer
du contenu sur un segment sont inquiets
non mais on s'entend qu'il s'est quand
même inhabituel pour maintenant
mais même à ce démantèlement fait sentir
comme comme si je faisais partie de la
gamme puis et ils méritaient partout
j'étais dans la réunion d'équipé bis et
m réussis savais que j'allais pas faire
d stories dans la zone de calmes et même
assistés comment allait-on veux te
comprennent comment ça marche pied dit
fait partie notre famille dit dans le
fond était invité là mais le but c'est
qu'ils couvrent un peu le travail a
candidaté réseaux sociaux mais eux ce
que j'ai trouvé général de leur force et
qui m'ont jamais demandé d'endosser qst
y ont jamais dit tu viens le pourquoi
convaincre les gens de voter q s sas je
veux dire je pense que ça s'est fait
naturellement parce que attention assez
confiance en eux sont assez confiant
leur plein appui de leurs idées n'ont
pas besoin de faire ses gammes gamme et
on lit ici le tri sont qu'un qui tourne
son podcast y est tellement confiant de
son argumentaire que y a pas besoin
si il n'y a pas besoin de demander
d'être partisan et ici comme si c'était
un vide puis mettons il s'assoit devant
moi depuis il va me convaincre de plomb
importe de peu importe le point qui
aurait qu'elle établit il convenu il va
me convenir avec eux j'ai l'impression
qu'ils sont tellement confiant à leur
projet de société car n'était de tétouan
s'est quand même
pkoi tu prends aucun parti montre
comment ça se passe puis la preuve
s'était pas senti utiliser cette
histoire non mais il voulait juste comme
le plus de jeunes possible à voter oui
c'est ça si je leur ai fait de toute
façon comme parler du fait que c'est
important les jeunes allaient voter mais
le steak aux huttes et de montrer
comment ça se passe en campagne
électorale et pour ce que j'ai dit oui
mais non je me suis jamais sentie écho
ici ou forcés à quoi que ce soit et ses
nuits ils m'ont dit carte blanche le
titre et le contenu tu veux tu fais le
nombre de stories ou de pause que tu
veux comme on veut juste on invite un
fake et fait pitié ils y ont invités
lyon est en fait un appel à tous ceux
qui ont acheté n'importe quel média qui
porterait g7 allait fixer ça démontre
aussi qu'est ils font confiance aux
créateurs y en a encore pris qu'un jour
ça marche
est ce que toi parce que ma blonde à lui
ce problème là dessus des débats clash
des médias traditionnels
est ce que ma blonde à ces fêtes étaient
avec alexandre à ce moment là puis
suivez la civelle
bus puis sont fait un peu intimidés par
une journaliste qui travaillait je pense
à ses côtés soir l'émission secrets pour
un journal sojourn armorial de la presse
puis de quand même que si vous faites le
bain on vient suivre avec votre pense on
n'est pas des médias mais qu'elle fait
presser comme ben j'ai comme pas il
sentait comme attac id de voir leur
espace pris par quelqu'un d'autre
le tu sautes de sens mais c'est sûr que
je me j'essaye de tout des modifications
qui y est je prenais j'essaie de prendre
les moments où il y avait justement pour
toutes les autres médias comme j'étais
privilégie j'étais dans leur autobus
fait comme sur la route teilleul autobus
prise par que l'autobus d'aimer dieu et
moi j'étais vraiment avec le fait que je
peux poser mes questions à manon était
peu de séparer les autres médias mais en
même temps c'est spécial parce que les
médias qui sont le puits qui suivent les
politiciens en campagne électorale
ils sont vraiment le un peu par
obligation parce que limiter les médias
vont envoyer un journaliste par partie
et qui ont un peu choix des clous pts
toujours posé des questions chaque fois
que comme une période de questions avec
un an menée après 30 jours de campagne
sous peu une seconde à cette journée le
gens ils ont posé la question est
comment allez-vous guidage roule c'est
que ça aussi je mange comme jeter vers
la fin la campagne fait que j'ai senti
qu'ils avaient quand même eu une
ouverture que les médias qui était later
peu comme mon avis est qu'il est chaud
mais je comprend d'où ça vient quand
même par exemple cette agressivité le
même temps la ceinture dans l'islam
parce que c'est mettons le travail de
tourner à l'essai quand même régie par
certains c'est un certain code vingtaine
normes certaines règles que le tarif
pileux tu vas chercher du monde qui ont
un gros reach qui sont déjà un peu parce
que le journaliste vaut entre guillemets
et neutre parce que je n'ai jamais
vraiment neutre
ces deux mois
un peu métier les journalistes vont se
faire un devoir de comme pour les
critiques de questions qui vont qui va
pour justement pour être celui qui écrit
quelques quel parti pris gros comme le
bruit que ça paraît peu puis essayer de
donner le là encore me débrouiller mais
une information objective dans ce cas là
si tu vas chercher juste du monde qui
ont des gros risques ce que tu cites
sont vendus davance parce qu'ils trient
but on part si petit diable venu vous en
pis finalement vous allez avoir plus
d'impact parce que tout ce train de
changer tout le système des téléjournaux
dans les clans les influences web est
iron & company et à prendre plus en plus
de place que tu vas chercher ces gens là
c'est juste que j'ai quand même qu'il ya
quand même quelque chose à se
questionner de d'éthique puis des
métiers mettons mettons les journaux il
y avait tout la possibilité je sais ce
qu'ils ont dans les faits aucun média tu
retiens c'est un journaliste qui serait
assigné à un autre parti tu peux pas
être python propre journal décide de ne
pas suivre un des partis qui au final va
se ramasser que quand même beaucoup de
députés à l'assemblée nationale
je peux pas vraiment être en mer que ce
parti la ffb loto si on veut une
couverture et puis c'est aussi je pense
pas qu'on soit capable de john lennon
mais si juge pas je pense pas non plus
qu'on prétend une journaliste n'était
jamais que je dirais que je suis allé je
pense pas que jesse les faits non plus
et on a comme un métier qui est pas
défini aux cris de contenus 60 ans que
c'est vraiment vague
donc si j'avais j'avais pas cette
prétention le puits aussi pour vrai j'ai
posé des questions qui aucun midi qui
est posée puis j'ai fait ma recherche
avancée j'en sais quoi c'est quoi les
questions qui seront posées qi jolie vue
rapidement une journée c'était tout à la
faire c'est moi j'étais là pendant la la
controverse du communisme des genres et
manu qui souhaiteraient dit communiste
qui aiment ce test toutes les questions
ce genre mais leur tête sortait pas
marxiste maintenant j'en fais comme
année c'est comme j'ai ils y ont fait le
tour les journalistes puis oui
clairement et j'avais dit j'ai une
inflation et québec solidaire
sauf que sentant témoin du challenge qui
d'utiliser ce pour leur poser des
questions vue du celtix je demandais à
gâbles pourquoi il peut rester neutre en
tant que militant à la place des deux
prendra voire facile entre guillemets
kidal et en politique j'ai demandé à mon
nom a qu'ici c'est ben beau supporter
les agriculteurs du québec mais on sait
que on sait que l'agriculture animal
bien c'est un des dignes des causes
principales du changement climatique
vous faites tout votre campagne là
dessus pourquoi vous en parler plus que
ce que le rebond
elle dit qu'il fallait il fallait
repenser la façon de cultiver mais tu es
là tu y est quand même resté vague
l'assemblée nationale
mais je suis la victime des mêmes effets
et transitions métier c'est vrai parce
que il faut dire qu'ils aient c'est vrai
que ça fait vivre le québec c'est un dj
raph et puis si c'est malheureux que ça
soit sur le dos des animaux t sauf que
le jeune presque pile là mais évidemment
mais reste toujours en mains tu dis à
tous ces gens le depuis john c b demande
que font pas d'études pas ce qui
m'attend lyon hérité la ferme les
détails de leur prime et c'est vrai
qu'il faut on transforme en coulée s'est
définitivement toi cela par contre le
faux camaïeu mais par contre il faut
qu'il faut qu'ils en aient une pique il
faut que ça se passe enclenché je pense
que les gens ont peur de soulever cette
question le on en parle au niveau de la
cité comme normal les gens entre amis en
famille on en parle d'eux comme will et
dégarnissent mme leblanc mais en
politique on ya une personne pendant les
élections fédérales
une personne qui a parlé contre le lobby
des producteurs laitiers
c'est maxime bernier action derniers y
ont comparé le lobby des producteurs
laitiers à la mafia celui ci on disait
au temps du simple et prenez dorlin pied
ont financé à plein
la campagne du parti conservateur en
beauce est là puis on assimiler
complètement maxime bernier puis l'on y
ont détruit sa campagne civile c'est à
dire une personne que mentionné quoi que
ce soit contre lobby de production
agroalimentaire il s'est fait défoncer
par ce deal du meti lui promet en plus
je connais rien là dedans le fait que
choisir des quoi de mon chapeau mais
libre armes en compte la gestion de
l'offre le fait que comme tout ce régime
ne pouvait gagner juste qui compte sur
mon point c'est à dire ceux c'est
exactement la raison des personnes qui
s'attaque à cette industrie l'heure
parce que sinon ils vont se faire juste
des fonds s'il imagine québec soldats
qui arrive en un et nous on veut on veut
qu'en 2030 tout le monde soit vegan
bonne façon de forêt ruiner complètement
sa campagne
ouais c'est clair mais je pense qu'ils
ont peu de choix mon pauvre le choix mon
idée d'un parent qui parle tant que dans
l'éducation des transports et de
l'environnement
tu peux pas ne pas parler d'un strict
encore plus polluantes non mais je pense
qu'ils en sont ils sont conscients c'est
mon intelligence et leur suivi d'un
podcast justement si on arrêtait ne
mangent de la viande mais conscient que
c'est un vrai enjeu ouais ouais bah si
ces indices sont conscients je pense
juste que c'est ce qu'elle a fait aussi
jusqu'à ce que des fois on oublie qu'on
pense que les politiciens y tourner les
coins ronds dans la réponse ce qui est
bon c'est pas le même dans toutes les
parties mais surtout québec solidaire
c'est des représentants si peu les chefs
de partis donc ils doivent aussi
consulter leurs membres
je pense que pour ce que des fois on a
l'impression qu'ils sont vraiment
prendre de court avec une question passé
c'est vrai parce que si on on peut
parler avant en assemblée ont peu
répondu m ils peuvent essayer de
formuler une réponse mais sasp ce qui se
passe bachir leurs prochaines assemblées
par les membres qui sont comme
de quoi de parler pour nous tandis
qu'e.on à les combattre mais dont le
lobby des producteurs laitiers non c'est
fait que je pense que je poursuis aussi
que mon nom était comme votre retour
dans un bus mais par exemple on a parlé
des lobbys qui elle me dit que c'était
comme évident que à qsf y aller jamais
embarqué dans 7 km
la statue dont tu parle surtout chamakh
avec celle d'acs une approche plutôt de
de la base vers le top se décide dans la
balle depuis la hausse et les paroles
plutôt que l'inversé qu'un chèque qui
voit plus décidé la bonne c'est soit que
si ce qui est en ma maman au gab
c 'est pas été voté plus beaux effets
pas prononcé c'est pas qu'ils ont les
mains liées dans le dos aux tiges ans
ils connaissent très bien leurs membres
qui connaissent très bien la ligne de
parti qui se décident dès jeudi n'ont
pas demandé l'autorisation à tous les
membres
à chaque fois qu'ils crèvent mission
qu'ils ont rédigé une motion mais reste
cube pour des grosses affaires tic qui
demanderaient justement un projet de
société et parce que ça serait vraiment
seul
ça prend ça prend du courage politique
pis c'est je pense que c'est difficile
aussi de mener ce projet le quand toi
même tu sens qui était peut-être peu
exemplaire si je dis je sais pas je peux
parler pour lui mais mettons gabriel ils
mangent l'avion mais je pense qu'on en
est conscient du problème mais il doit
pas nécessairement sentir qui sert bonne
personne peut être ai je sais pas très
possiblement très possiblement supposer
qu'il ya quand même éventuellement avoir
une réflexion à avoir sur dans un monde
où les médias ont moins en moins de
witch de pouvoir des influenceurs de
plus en plus amenés à devenir évidents
justement tu es que l' influence
d'influenceurs en a plus ou d'une
influence de certaines personnes ou
instant sur le web en avoir plus que que
certains médias traditionnels qui sont
régis par par plein de 1 des godes
pileux va falloir kayes
mais les codes les lois par rapport au
web se sent bien il va d'abord
puisqu'elle ne pourraient rentrer dans
les cinq prochaines années tout votre on
en parlais tantôt allemande mettant les
guides wild west les camions fait tirer
quelque chose de pas le droit de faire
ce
droit de faire un tirage comme ce que tu
fais pour loto-québec des tirages 5000
pièces sont fait tirer 5000 places parmi
le monde qui commandent pas le droit de
faire ce témoignage a fait en impose
pour faire tirer une bûche
techniquement j'ai pas le droit de faire
ce pas le droit de faire un tirage avec
moi je digresse d'ici cinq ans comme
fait retirer des voyages partir de la
fin tout ça va être régi après ce
l'aspect médiatique va être régi
éventuellement c'est sûr c'est sûr que
c'est sûr que oui sinon c'est trop de
pouvoir à des membres qui n'ont pas de
lois c'est l'oeil après un
bouleversement justement dans d'avec ces
nouveaux médias qui bouleverse justement
les politiques puissent exactement ce
que sa pensée chrétienne d'orienter
ouais mais pourquoi tout le monde capote
et que sa photo dans lwin le monde
capote parce que alors alors un week-end
un pouvoir à la une influence dont tout
le monde est jaloux de la grosse valise
il était bondé à savoir même une photo
comme ceux qui brisent l'internet est
les plus grands influenceurs rêve de ce
mois elisabeth guigou a le poids des
photos qui brisent l'internet comme seul
car le brésil est mis au point au moment
le à le retirer je pense le la photo
mais sur facebook s'était rendue je
pense à 12000 partage 12000 part dans le
mix des rémois on approche de mai le
partage se remettant le post concours
qu'on a faits dénoncés comme du jamais
vu à capote chien au culot tiers n'ont
cessé ce t1 lui snappy ça c'est en peu
de temps parce que je pense avoir le 21
ça va continuer de se propager comme
comme une traînée de poudre
mais si ce métier elles l'utilisent les
nouveaux métiers autrement a fait la
politique autrement sur sa saison ça
bouleverse des choses là c'est ça
bouleverse en crise mais depuis trois
catherine alors celui-ci est tellement
fine suite mais betty bouger défendre
catherine dorion des fauches comme
huawei à l'eau avait compris enfin la
bonne chose les fausses coop
c'est comme ça qu'on devrait faire la
politique me semble ça ne sonne
dangereux parce que tu es populisme
parce qu'à s'en cache pot des populismes
et je pense que c'est clairement ce
qu'est un café s'apprête merveilleux
comme ça peut être dangereux
c'est bête on releva qui était populaire
pied de l'arête un populisme et on le
tue ouais ouais genre g beauty rambo
gauthier
ouais sauf que c'est ce mais je pense
non mais t'es ok mais maintenant c'est
vrai que c'est pour le meilleur pour le
pays ce que je trouve les femmes
j'aurais dit mettons des filion moi
j'avoue que c'est toujours ça c'est
jamais bon c'est jamais bon ok mais mais
c'est ce cpie d'amener puis mettons sur
la tribune au monde en parle
j'ai quand même j'ai comme renouer
justement la raison parce que justement
entier est porteuse de messages d'un
message d'un projet puisse te ment à
suscite une émotion ce qu'est la
politique fait rarement mais est ce
qu'il est mais laïque en question est ce
qu est ce qu il faut avoir du beau de
l'émotivité puis de l'aider de la colère
aussi petit soit en politique ou il faut
juste avoir de la raison tout excité je
sais pas répondre à cette question mais
je trouve que ça représente la
population pis je pense qu'une des
raisons pour lesquelles les gens se sont
tellement détacher la politique parce
qu'ils sont peu représentées puis c'est
pour ce que catherine dorion époque dans
son contexte pour ceux qui en ont assez
des pommes dans son corps dans son côté
parce qu ils représentent les gens qui
servent d un qui
bip je trouve que c'est moi je trouve
que ça sa place pourquoi il y aurait une
manière de faire de la politique je veux
dire dans notre peuple
il fait pas de la politique de façon
traditionnelle on est tous d'accord
ouais monde est d'accord aussi karam
adapter la politique parce que autour de
cette table
ouais qu'on n'est pas d'accord tu as
monory qui fait de la politique parce
que non mais mettons moi je suis bien
plus pour d'accord avec ces propos c'est
avec la manière parce que c'est cette
politique la déconne voilà quelqu'un qui
quelqu'un qui s'exprime avec des mets
ton admettons qu'on place au québec qui
coince experts avec des expressions
québécoises pour parler sans langue de
bois de toutes les dossier mais qu'il
fait de façon avec laquelle je peux
aligner ma pensée qu'il fait façon
respectueuse puis kiki pas misogyne
piqué pas raciste ben moi quelqu'un qui
parle mon langage c'est sûr que je vois
plus le suis quelqu'un qui parle pour
rien
ou pour dire quelque chose qui qui qui
qui répondent pas aucune question et
dans le choc tant que ce qui fait le
pourquoi le money et s'identifier à lui
le monde vote pour lui passer comme away
lui parle comme moi puis il a rien à
faire wade s'est fixé comme c'est comme
on disait dans les meilleurs et pour les
messieurs
mais comme catherine dorion pour la même
raison qui va pas créer deux acteurs un
peu kitty ils disent d'eux les messages
comble à nice 1-2 et fait notre vie avec
core débit
bennis enders dans le fond c'est le job
la gauche pratiquement wiseman pièce est
un peu plus et un peu plus langue de
bois mais aussi gebe ya le fait qu'il ya
une carrière politique dans la chanson
dans une carrière politique et pitch est
là dedans
pillot comme lui du redouté pour ses
idéaux lot toute sa ville béninoise
vérité ce sera d'oublier vraiment
policiers de com de formation des
canaris
alors que de nombreux hommes j'ai
l'impression que j'ai mon impression
même si je pense que quand il s'élance
en campagne et voyez ce juste comme une
étape dans sa carrière de businessmen
d'entrepreneurs
qui de jean roy demande dans sa tête m
je pense pas qu'ils passaient sur moi je
dis bonjour à tous les gens commentaires
prononce le mot de cinq lettres commence
par plus de monde viendrait pas de casse
le rebond de franchir quand ma part j'ai
eu plus de monde qu'on pense qui
baguenaudent chambre d'écho que le monde
voudrait que c'est ridicule
exploité dans le christ c'est un sujet
tellement pas la raison c'est aux états
unis une autre ici joron par lucho mais
la majorité quand même juste une colle
qui pool sipa nicole on va bien non mais
c'est ici quand même il ya quand même
une majorité de la population qui
pendant le même sens visé cette personne
me mets aux states et 55 en outre au
moment qui a été 50 50 des gens qui sont
allés voter
ouais puis il ya des gens fous leur ai
dit qu'ils étaient les gens les volent
carrière avec dès qu'ils sont pas au top
c'est pas rien qui le forma dans son
tracteur qui votent pour simple ouais
mais je pense qu'on l'ait vu avec les
élections fédérales ici aussi que en y
portant différents t on à l'impression
que au québec et on pense tout un petit
peu pareil qui ait aucun vendeur on
pense aux appareils mais on est quand
même très divisés puis au lait de plus
en plus mais on est divisés mais le
discours le discours ben populiste
mettons à la tchaux pompe piscine c'est
non ces maisons mais maxime bernier a
essayé ça paponi le jello qui me semble
qu'il avait in qui avait eu qu'à enjoy
la course 2 course au leadership mais
c'est son nom mais il y avait une femme
lucky qui était très dans les méthodes
cruelles à trembloter
vraiment c'est en espèces en inspirer
plus à propos ni non plus tu es fax est
pas un style qui nous rejoint mais en
même temps il n'y aura pas une autre
tranche avec les mêmes idées -les jb oui
en a toujours eu mais avec si je pense
que c'est quelque chose d'unique dans
l'histoire et je dirais pas qu'on a la
chance de voir se sont un peu le malheur
de bourse
mais voici comme la fin d'un cycle aussi
le ticket com que kate et on essayera de
la gauche et la droite on essaie t on
voit dans une certaine direction mais
s'étend dans le site que chomsky comme
un peu un dernier cru deux vagues avant
même espace mais j'ai comme moi ce qui
me fait peur c'est que j'ai l'impression
que ça vaut encourager certains et
certaines certains politiciens de la
droite à aller encore plus au nord à
l'extrême
parce que si on pense à james qui disait
au début de sa campagne
comparé à ce qu'il réussit à faire
maintenant il répond pu faire ces choses
le début c'est parce qu'ils ont c'est
tellement habituée qu'elle savait pas la
leur ce qu'ils disent est ce qui faisait
que ces choses là on était un peu
acceptable yocum élargi la fenêtre de
caisse qui correct politiquement
tu veux dire il répond pu partir sa
campagne électorale avec je vais c'est
paris les familles à la frontière il ya
quand même par sa campagne avec la
barbade est possible s'il y avait des
jeux id journal il déjà rentré avec avec
l'autre côté de l'accueil
oui c'est clair mais certaines
déclarations qui faisait ou dubuc ont
choqué on les relate même pu maintenant
dans les médiévales ont tellement s'est
rendu quinze jours avec imagine veut
dire quelqu'un qui promet même des
logiques qui veut se présenter
maintenant il se représente mais me
tombe après lui le savait depuis cet
automne je vais le plus rapide aussi
déceler les patins et les think you are
a peur de lui là ne se quittent pas si
je vais enfin je vois
enfin l'erreur que j'ai faite tantôt
c'est la deuxième guerre mondiale
[Applaudissements]
non mais c'est maintenant c'est arrivé
seul
oui on est on est on a sombré dans
l'horreur qui doit le pire le pays qui
lui manquait pour faire écrit bon il ya
eu d'autres d'autres tragédies puis
d'autres horreurs après ce mais mettons
je pense que depuis cet événement on est
plus sensible mettons nous nos antennes
à jean rouaud non non non non genre seul
mauvais apparentés sont peut-être plus
affinités mais ce qui arrive c'est quand
on le sait tout le temps après mais où
on veut pas le voir pendant que ça soit
ajouté
je veux dire il y en a eu d'autres
génocides en prélude au pid idée de
l'amérique était en allemagne encore le
parti nazi qui existe qui est quand même
des sièges
les sièges ou bayer fort dans les
sondages mais il est quand même le non
sens qu'il n'y ait pas il n'est pas
évident il ya peu jean 0% la population
qui vote pour eux trois ils toujours des
dix groupes néo-nazis et encore le juger
ici
le groupuscule néo nazi qui se dira si
c'est ça car nos médecins mais
honnêtement je le sais pas ce dont tu
parles mais oui oui il existe encore des
genres betty mettons en arts langues
athlètes en général je pense que pas
plus anti nazi probablement aujourd'hui
non sécurité je pense que moi je pense
que c'est clair mais reste encore
aujourd'hui presque 200 ans plus tard
ils ont encore entre le puits sont
encore au métier c'est fou parce que on
se dédouane vraiment beaucoup de
semences en tant que les pays en rien
fait que pendant la guerre un tipi
irions tout clamé leur innocence piqué
il savait juste peu ce qui se passait
mais janvier une gagne d'historiens qui
son coeur
il avait porté les toutes les horreurs
qui se passe à ce moment le tri après
quand il eut les procès tout le monde
est comme tomber en bas de leur
challenger ben voyons avoir su on aurait
tellement arrêter ce avant qui sait
vraiment facile à dire après et qui dit
je pense que il ya beaucoup de pays vie
de populations qui ont comme qui ont
appris de cette cette atrocité mais
pourquoi d'abord depuis ce temps le yoyo
tant gêné s'est dit autant d des
dictateurs pis l'écart civile de tout
succès continue d'arriver mais que ça
exactions un genre de conflit qui a
appelé ses le ce qu'on voit c'est jade
et des guérillas des guerres civiles al
internes pdi métier que j'adore kiki
guerre mondiale mondiale
c'est je pense qu'on en a vu les signes
fille maintenant on lisait à tout prix
mais j'espère et on espère on espère on
espère en a convenu m supposer que
kitsch hommes visent à un point mais il
invité aux states le ça détruit famille
le célèbre jeu mais avec raison
avec raison aussi je veux dire moi je me
fais souvent dire comme un tout et
peut-être pas besoin d'avoir la même
opinion que les gens pour être amis avec
un os qui à un certain point
sauf que quand tu votes ou que tu
supportes quelqu'un qui veut
littéralement effacer une partie de la
population
je comprends peu comment commence à
profiter avec moi a dit ou quand tu
crois peu aux droits des populations
marginalisées et population lgbt qui
plus quand tu leur enlève des jo dicte
leur empêche d dans l'armée dès après
demain je comprends que ça divise les
familles puis j'ai le goût de dire pour
le mieux dit oui c'est triste
sauf km2 on en parlait aussi qu'il
s'épanouisse non plus deux comme vivent
dans une espèce de façade de jeu
on s'entend bien mais dans le fond que
ton cousin il prêt raciste pillet mme
pollet femme et moi j'aimerai savoir que
mon cousin c'est vraiment quelque chose
puis j'ai eu cette discussion avec ma
blonde et on parle souvent de ce genre
d'affaires la plus active et spi pitt et
moi mon approche est beaucoup plus
inclusive dont que je vais à tout prix
pas cherché à me chicaner parce que j'aï
le conflit je parais g sauf que sauf que
ma blonde sait pas que pièce qu son
point je le comprends absolument
moi je l'appliquerais pas dans ma vie à
moi mais je comprends son point
absolument de dire faut que tu fu foot
challenge des gens sur des trucs que tu
juges complètement unique c'est
inacceptable ne pas le choix tu peux pas
c'est pas juste rester en silence puis 6
je comprends ce mois je peux regarder
l'appliquer encore que je progresse de
médecins des farc en qu'est ce ce
comportement est inacceptable fait que
ça va se faire que soit on est en froid
aux souffrances par [ __ ] et j'ai
beaucoup plus de ponts avec aucun ami et
puis j'ai pas l'intention de le faire
dans les prochaines sauf que je peux
comprendre d'où ça vient je peux
comprendre a dit est ce ton comportement
mettons je pourrais je pourrais
comprendre emmené j'ai failli arrêter de
parler à mon ancien beau frère adam
parce que on avait une question sur
l'indépendance du québec puis puis on
était complètement en désaccord ou
est-ce qu'on est arrivé à un point où
est-ce que c'était comme si on marchait
vap qu'il y avait un mur les
conversations arrivant un bureau pierre
un mur puis il y avait aucun issue
évoquant une issue dans la conversation
était complètement en désaccord sur
plusieurs points le sais j'ai comme du
maine je pense qu'il faut que je m'en
aille
il dit je pense que oui je
si jamais reparler de ça on est resté en
bons termes qui on est resté à militer
mais on n'agit plus jamais réaborder sûr
parce qu'on arrivait rarement un poème
c'est comme nom moi je peux pas accepter
je vais pas dire à chacun quelque chose
de très important pour moi pour qu'on se
dise on n'en comprend de dire si ton âme
et qui restera pignon respect que la
mienne vous vivez lessive et mène pas
dans tous les cas maintenant parce que
quand c'est une question d'école tu
penses tu que mes amis ont droit de
vivre ou peut sérieusement ce lieu avec
certains avec certaines politiques
acteurs présents si tu penses tu que mes
amis mérite de tourner dans le pays de
leur parents jean monnet si comme
comment après tu veux quand on est jeune
on passe par deux comment compenser par
dessus comment on ignore ce puits jeudi
6 mai jean mus il n'y a pas eu mon avec
qui je suis vraiment pas d'accord puis
comme j'ai quand même pas couper les
ponts avec qu'après après son ambition
personnelle de quel genre de relation tu
veux avoir avec ses personnels
m mais je pense que comme on le disait
plus tôt c'est des conversations qui
sont nécessaires qui peut oui qui
peuvent faire mal qui divise vite ou pas
le goût le de pognon avec ta famille de
paul goude de venir avec tes amis mais
en même temps comment et quand tu crois
en quelque chose comment tu peux une
épaule fin août au musée d'essen qui ne
leur a dit ce mardi
mais c'est ce qui a été cédée codé on
évite le sujet ouais mais ça c'est bien
mais c'est dommage mais à manier aussi
c'est que lisent moins on y multiplie t
qui est tellement de facettes pieds
tellement de choses dans le monde sur
lesquels on est aisé pignon qu'ils ont
reçu coupes et des ponts c'est mettons
ressentant foule sur 99 à faire votre
coupé les ponts sur de la forme et c'est
ça le passé quoi parce que des enfants
qui sont se mettant dans ce cas là c'est
exactement pour ça que j'ai beau coupé
les ponts avec lui
parce que on s'entend pas sur ce qui
s'est passé important pour moi parce
important pour toi tu aimais tant la
coke et j'arrivais à noël qui j'ai un
cousin ou gens aiment ou non qui est
vraiment déplacé que des commentaires
mise à genoux tout le monde qui touche
les fesses la cousine de même à temps je
parle plus ici
après ça ça servira comme ak c'est quoi
le sujet t on s'il y avait des enfants
que je capable de passer par-dessus
blake comme bombay ok que si on n'est
pas d'accord mais je pourrais m'imaginer
été être avoir une relation proche avec
quelqu'un sur des trucs fondamentaux
mais qui viennent toucher les valeurs
qui prouvait la sangle non
ça se pourrait que j'avais besoin d'être
un peu dessus avoir le droit de
friendfeed en russe je me suis même pas
si je peux tu revendiqué avoir le droit
de faire
[Rires]
merci beaucoup
un pare feu mais tout des sujets qui
m'intéressent annoncé ça c'est ce qu'est
ce qu'on souhaite parce que sans les
hauts et bas jean donnera de la santé
est partout et qui elles continuent à
vivre de mon métier et que je puisse
écouter écouter non pas dans tous les
points de vente au québec